right lobster first off off with its
laws now from their tail lift open and
twist okay now open up add tail press it
in between your hand Parma ham in and
squeeze the top part that tail it free
squeeze
once it squeeze hold it open and twist
and literally do not burst lobster and
then when you get down to the third one
thumb on here push in and gently
literally pull out the tail from their
claws separate the knuckle pull the
first floor twist and pull turn out get
rid of that water again separate the
knuckle twist drain out and pull from
there big knife hold up the claw in
twist burst off your finger in off of
the floor knuckles off there through
here slice one half
down push from there
open up beautiful okay one knuckle and
take this off these little beauties have
a touch of meat I'll show you where
these bits here top try slice at an
angle rolling pin at the back push and
out comes the leg these are tiny little
legs but the meat inside is so sweet
it's extraordinary again slice at an
angle open up the knuckle down in and
squeeze from there take the head cut
send it calls off there's a V here go
round present your lobster take out that
that's just a touch of the carcass show
you why move that keep that nice and
upright
there's
our tail there's our core inside before
the claw is each knuckle second knuckle
then you've gotta make the head
touchable that is how to extract your
meats formula good luck